bet
bonheur Sébastien deoi je suis comédien
et notamment au sein de l'association
éclat de Lille des clous d'un hôpital
j'ai rencontré plein de gens qui qui
évolué dans le monde du CIRC du théâtre
et c'est ce qui m'a donné en premier le
goût le goût du
spectacle les transmission avec le le
personnel soignant ça nous aide à
adapter nos interventions ces différent
de faire une intervention pour un petit
bébé d'un mois que pour un plus grand de
3 ans tous les artistes qui travaillent
dans l'association sont d'une part des
artistes professionnels polyvalents et
formé spécifiquement pour ce type
d'intervention la transformation elle
elle elle me sert à moi en tant que
personne de un petit peu de protection
prêt 1 2 3 2 2
à l'heure actuelle on intervient tous
les mardis sur l'hôpital de Saint-Denis
tous les jeudis sur l'hôpital de
Saint-Pierre quand les financements nous
le permettent puisque on manque de on
manque de sous on manque de financement
donc oninvient plus qu'une fois tous les
jours oh
là il subissent les soins ils subissent
la journée
subissent les examens et quand il y a
les clown qui arrivent c'est un peu
d'irréel qui rentent dans leur vie le
principe de l'enfant c'est c'est le jeu
et avec bah avec ses clown on arrive un
petit peu à dédramatiser
l'hospitalisation et oui et parce qu'il
est midi on vous dit bon appétit les
amis bon
appétit bon appétit les amis de midi bon
appétit mange bien j'espère tous
ensemble ils arriveront à financer ce
projet qui qui serait enfin qui est pour
moi d'utilité publique plus plus plus
bon appétit et puis
merci